on a tiny Australian island live a flock
of little penguins they nest there for
six months of the year and at one point
there were over 200 penguins on the
island but that changed when the
villains of this story snuck in at low
tide foxes were able to make their way
to the island where they attacked the
defenseless penguins and left less than
ten surviving this story was headed
towards a sad end for the Penguins until
the appearance of an unlikely hero
oddball a marina sheepdog
oddball lived on a chicken farm and when
her eccentric owner Ellen Marsh heard of
the dilemma on Middle Island
he knew that oddball might be able to
help for what oddball does on the farm
is to protect the chickens from fox
attacks at first it seemed like a crazy
idea and convincing the local council
was a huge hurdle but when the
population of penguins was down to
almost nothing they agreed to give it a
shot two oddball the Penguins were just
chucks and dinner suits once she was
familiar with them she could recognize
any intruders within a week of being on
the island there were no Fox prints to
be seen oddball did a great job
protecting her new friends and marinas
have become a frequent companion on the
island since oddball in the Penguins are
such odd and unexpected friends but a
lovely example of animals helping one
another it is amazing that Nature has
been able to put a little bouncer in
place it is of course also natural for
foxes to hunt but as introduced species
it's not meant to be here and not these
defenseless penguins oddball helps to
stop something that isn't fair she
protects those who can't protect
themselves extremely dedicated to her
flock this is one dog that saved a
penguin colony from elimination